and another breaking news story here at  six we've been monitoring throughout the  day a shooting involving metro police  officers in the downtown las vegas area  it happened near main street and  foremaster around lunchtime today metro  police say officers were on patrol when  they noticed two people in a fight one  of the officers reportedly got out of  the police car to break it up when one  of those in the fight started to charge  at the officer police say that person  then reached into their pocket to grab  what appeared to be a weapon  subject quickly closed distance on the  officer as he was still charging at the  officer  and still possessed an item in his hand  the officer then retrieved his firearm  discharging his firearm striking the  suspect  in the midst of all of this the officer  lost his footing he fell was taken to  the hospital to be treated the person  shot was also taken to the hospital we  are told with non-life-threatening  injuries